who wants to live forever hey folks
let's talk about some lgbtq plus
representation and specifically
i want to kind of tackle something
initially starting in the form of a
question that i see asked usually
mockingly when i talk about things like
the barrier queers trope which i've
dedicated an entire video to and also
dealt with specifically in regards to
star trek uh more recently and in that
one i
got very upset and literally
yelled at creators
writers show runners what have you and
if you're not going to put in the time
just stop
now one of the questions that would get
asked again often in a
uh kind of mocking tone or at least
that's what i tended to
feel like was coming off of it it's text
you can't always get toned let's try and
get the benefit of the doubt is this
idea of well
does that mean that you need a shield
do queer characters need to be in
invincible
immortal they can never die
so to pull a quote from
the simpsons uh the short answer is yes
with an if long answer is no with a but
because as is always the case with these
things
it's context dependent
i always get so frustrated when anybody
be it a video creator somebody on
twitter or somebody in my comments
basically trying to boil something down
to an either or
like oh so it's always this i'm like
no nothing is always however
there are some things that really should
become the way that it happens more
often than not
at least for the time being until some
things get sorted out without
reiterating
all the stuff i've already talked about
with the inception and the persistence
and the issues
with barrier queers as a trope full
video there if you need it
i will say this whether or not
the killing of a queer character in any
given piece of
media and obviously i'm talking
fictional media here
uh that impact and
and really kind of how badly that's
gonna read
will be decided by a couple of factors
such as how close is their death to
the point at which it is revealed that
they are in fact queer
supernatural or how
immediate from their introduction is it
established that they are dead or we are
forced to witness that they die
star trek discovery but there's another
element that's kind of what i want to
focus on here
and that is the idea of tokenism
which is something i actually haven't
tackled in specific on
this channel before now tokenism
as a practice is is a bad thing now
here's the thing to remember tokenism
is not simply the presence
of minority people in a
story a company an organization what
have you
generally when tokenism is talked about
as say
in a workplace what it refers to is the
practice of hiring
an incredibly small number of
diversity hires i hate using the term
but that is the reality of it
so that it does not appear as if there
is a hiring bias
at that company where the company has
no actual interest and doesn't care
about actually ensuring a diversity
of its work populace or a diversity of
thought
it just knows the it just it's
self-aware enough to know the optics are
really
bad if everybody in the company is
exactly the same
so i'm not trying to pick on on them but
you know if the whole company is
white cis males if you have
at least a woman a person of color
a out queer person in there
then even though only one does not
meaningfully
make them a presence in the organization
it does give a shield
for that organization that employer to
go
oh but look and that one
see it's the appearance
of diversity but it is always
only aiming for the absolute basic
rudimentary appearance of it
now as i said the term kind of
originated more
from employee and hiring practices
now when talking about it in terms of
entertainment
and media tokenism is a thing
and when it happens it is often
damaging for the groups being
represented now i say that as someone
who has said in the past and i stand by
this
i would rather have problematic
representation than no representation
because at least
problematic representation is a starting
point you have something that you can
work on if you're not there at all then
you might as well not exist
as far as things are concerned now i say
that and yes
you could probably show me examples
where i would go no just don't put us
there
it will have to do with specifics of the
depictions again nothing is
ever always remember that so i
kind of talked about the issues of
tokenism in an employment environment it
is
a veneer of diversity where none exists
but there's an additional layer that
gets involved when you are talking about
a media depiction
of a minority group any minority group
and that is if it is a token character
which is not always the case for
single instance representation not every
instance
of only one member of a minority group
appearing among the cast
is tokenism but all but pretty much all
instances of tokenism have
only the one so like correlation not
causation
when you only have the one instance
that character is carrying a lot
more weight in terms of
the impression that they are giving to
the audience be they
members of that minority in which case
you have
a single character and people who are
actually share
commonalities with that character have
to look at that and go
that is my representative in this piece
of fiction
to everyone else who isn't me and if you
aren't a member of that minority
you are seeing that one character and
for
this story and the course of this movie
this tv show this book what have you
they are your only representative for
that and what that means
implicitly sometimes explicitly but
almost always implicitly at the very
least
it implies that this is what all members
of that minority are like
again there are ways to dampen this in
terms of how well-rounded that character
is not leaning on stereotypes and
cliches is gonna
go a long way towards helping you avoid
that issue if you've only got the one
representation
but that's kind of why
my answer to should queer characters be
immortal is a soft yes
is this exact reason i've known it
before i did a video
on uh mortality rates for queer
characters in film
it's not just that we get killed
in a lot of movies tv shows books comics
etc
it's that when we do we
we as a queer audience
often have to watch the
queer character die our
soul representative of our life
experience
is who we have to watch die
or often times even when that isn't the
case
and there's more than one usually
they're a couple
and we have to watch one half of a
couple die so we're still looking at a
50
mortality rate with the remaining 50 now
in mourning and it
feels like an attack
when you watch it often enough and i'm
even gonna extend an olive branch
to a kind of viewer who probably has not
watched this far into the video
if we're being completely honest but i'm
gonna try it anyway
you folks who have been complaining
about doctor who
the last few series you know who you are
the ones who have been commenting and my
comments other people's comments
possibly been making videos about
how every single straight white male who
appears
in the chibnall and jodie whitaker era
of doctor who
is shown to be an idiot or a villain
there are no competent
righteous good straight
white male characters on doctor who i
know you complain about and i'm not
i'm not even gonna run the numbers to
find out how true that is because
honestly
how true it is in reality is irrelevant
to what i'm about to say
if you have ever felt that way at any
point even if you don't feel that way
now
if you ever felt that way then you
got a taste
of what it feels like to have
every instance of representation that
you see that looks like you
feel negative either because they are
depicted as villainous
or as stereotypes or because they are
getting
killed every time
you see them and again it probably isn't
actually every time it probably isn't
every single straight cis white male
character on doctor who who
is incompetent and or evil it probably
isn't every single queer character that
i see
in movies and tv and whatnot who ends up
dying or
i have to watch see the pain of seeing
their partner die or what have you
but it's often enough that it certainly
feels
like it's every time and that's the
problem with token representation
and again that is not to say that you
can't have a single representative of a
minority
but you need to realize the weight
of doing that whatever you do
to that character you are metaphorically
doing
to that entire population if the
implication
is that queer people are disposable
because they're treated that way
and they are killed off again
i will cite for me the most egregious
example in something that
is a show that i actually watch was in
the doctor who
new year's special resolution not this
most recent one but the one before
where a character is established as gay
and then immediately killed
when you do that what you're saying is
queer
people are disposable
so should we have a mortal gaze
yeah for a while i would kind of like to
see that
and not because i can't handle
watching people like me be depicted as
anything other than
perfect angels who live through
everything i mean that's shallow i don't
need that and certainly it helps
in any given depiction if they are not
the soul or part of a couple and then
that couple is the sole
queer representation in your medium
because here's the thing i had to dig at
the
doctor who example for because i've
actually seen people make that argument
that all straight cis white men on
doctor who are shown in a negative light
but the thing is
most of the time when a
white cis male character
is shown in any form of media
and is beaten up
the characters killed or they're a
despicable human
being that doesn't get an outcry
and the reason is
that group doesn't have token
representation
they have ample representation you
didn't like this one
here's 10 more in the same movie don't
worry about it
we don't have that
and that is why
i at this point have drawn a hard line
and said just stop with burying your
queers
with killing gay characters with killing
trans characters with killing non-binary
characters
whatever the case may be
because so
little care is happening
with what is often token representation
if you're going to represent us yes i am
going to ask please
handle with care not because of my tiny
fragile ego
my ego is pretty stable and i've been
watching this nonsense go
on for almost four decades now
i can take it but the point is
i shouldn't have to
and anyone who doesn't have my ego
also shouldn't have to
so don't ever tell
queer people complaining about how
someone that we relate to or is meant to
represent us
dies and you go i don't complain when
they kill a white man
yeah and you shouldn't because it's not
equivocal
because you are better represented and
your representation is not token
and the few times i say you and i'm
talking collectively
bear with me and understand i'm not
trying to lump everyone together but
those kinds of people who will say that
i don't complain when a
white male dies like yeah but you do
when you feel like
there's bad representation for all the
white men in something
you do complain that's why
we do because oftentimes
it's just the one
person
so it would actually
help if those characters
if they are the sole representation
until such time
as we get to that end goal that i've
talked about where representation is so
normalized that nobody notices anymore
until we are there yeah handling with
kid gloves
would actually be a big improvement
over how things have been for a long
time
and if you feel that i'm trying to
stifle writer's creativity
i'm not telling anybody what they can or
can't write
i'm making a request as an audience
member
as a creative as a writer
i'm asking you please
think really really hard
i know how confident and precious we can
get about our own work
if somebody tells you that this
depiction
feels harmful to them
i'm not saying you have to go by that
person's word maybe get a second or
third opinion
from somebody from the same group but at
the very least
listen and just to kind of make the
point finally
should we have more immortal queer
characters
well off the top my head
for an immortal queer character is jack
harkness and jack harkness
is awesome so yeah
more of that please thank you very much
for listening and for sticking all the
way through
i have a patreon if you want to support
what i do this is in fact how i am my
living that is how i cover my bills and
am able to eat
and afford equipment and everything else
that i need to make this
a thing any amount you're able to give
helps but even if you can't
there are other things you can do to
help i have merch
links down in the description liking
sharing subscribing
costing nothing also helps me out and
whatever your thoughts are on what i've
talked about
politely drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it
but you also don't have to do any of it
like i say i make recommendations i'm
offering guidance
i'm not definitively telling anybody
what to do because at the end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]